what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight prediction video in my last video
I answered several of the questions that
many of you had and I promised I would
do a follow-up to that Q&A video that
way more of you could get your questions
answered too so today I will be giving
more of my season 8 predictions based on
some of the questions you have asked but
before I get started I want to remind
everyone about the new giveaway that I'm
doing Game of Thrones season 7 comes out
on blu-ray and DVD next month and I will
be giving two copies away if you want a
chance to win one of these copies just
click the link that I have provided down
below in the description of the video
good luck to everyone now let's get
started the first question is from Nayla
Parvez do you think Samwell Tarly will
play an important role in season 8 yes I
absolutely believe Sam will play an
important role in the end technically he
has already played a big role because he
discovered all the dragonglass on
Dragonstone
thanks to Samwell Tarly Jon knew exactly
where to go to get enough dragonglass to
arm almost every soldier in the north
but I think Sam will make at least one
more big discovery before the great war
ends Sam stole a bunch of books and
documents before he left the Citadel and
I think when season 8 begins Sam will
find out something of great importance
on one of those old pages he has with
him Sam didn't just grab any old books
off the shelves when he left the Citadel
in the middle of the night you could
tell this was somewhat premeditated
because Sam knew exactly where to go and
what to take and I think there must be
something here that can help them win
the war or find out what the hell the
night King actually wants Plus Sam still
has hearts bein with him how Star Lee's
ancestral Valyrian steel sword when Sam
left the Citadel they made sure the
sword was visible just enough so that we
could see it sticking up out of the
buggy this sword will be put to use and
it will kill at least one white Walker
the sword is called hearts bane so maybe
this sword needs to be plunged into the
knight king's heart rate where the
dragon glass is who really knows but we
shall see soon enough the next question
is from Amy Higgins Aria has not
finished her list do you think we will
see her finish it do you think Oreo will
kill Cersei the last time aria
sited her list was in season six during
her training at the house of black and
white arias hit list was significantly
shorter than it used to be because Aria
did have Melisandre in Cyril and Payne
on there too but now they aren't which
is weird because they are technically
still alive but according to her most
recent list or only two people left
which are Cersei Lannister and Gregor
Clegane it's kind of hard to say whether
or not aria will be the one to kill them
because there are so many other people
that want them dead also I think in
order for Aria to be able to do this she
will need to find the right opportunity
to be able to get close enough to kill
one of them or both of them I know some
people think she may use Jaime or
Littlefinger's face and with one of
those faces she may be able to gain
access inside the red keep in King's
Landing then work her way to killing
Cersei and/or the mountain but to be
100% honest with you I don't think Arya
is actually gonna be the one to kill
them
I think Jaime Lannister is destined to
kill Cersei in the show and I still
think the Hound is destined to kill his
brother in this show as well I think
Jaime killing Cersei and the Hound
killing the mountain would be the most
satisfying ways for them to die but
that's my opinion
Arya Stark certainly has the skills and
the motive to do this also but I'd say
there might be only a 25% chance she
will be the one to actually do it the
next question is from Katrina
Salazar Jaime Lannister and Brienne of
Tarth do you think there will be more
scenes with them together seems like
Brienne may have strong feelings for
Jaime or attraction if we United what do
you think their storyline will be well I
think Brienne definitely has strong
feelings for jamey and Jaime definitely
has strong feelings for Brienne
they may not share the exact same
feelings but they both care about each
other a lot I think they will reunite
once again Jamie left Cersei in King's
Landing and he made sure to hide who he
was as best that he could I think he
will ride north to join the fight
against the army of the Dead in Brienne
will do her best to see that Jaime isn't
killed by one of the Starks when he
arrives Jaime will eventually have to
face the music and answer for his crimes
against bran stark but Brienne will
vouch for Jaime by explaining to them
that he has a changed man and she may
even tell everyone the true story about
Jimmy
the Mad King the same story Jamie shared
with Murray and when they bathed
together
I think the Starks will ultimately
accept Jamie's help and allow him to
fight alongside them but that doesn't
mean Jamie won't die I have always had
this feeling that Jamie would do one of
the most selfless acts of honor by
sacrificing his own life to save
another's like I have said before this
show started with Jamie trying to kill
one of the Starks but it could end with
him saving one of the Starks and if he
dies doing this he could die in the arms
of the woman he loves
which is something Jamie said he wanted
and that woman would be Brienne the next
question is from a Antonio patrasche do
you think Jorah Mormont will die and if
so how
sir Jorah is one of the very few people
to have been around since the very
beginning and it's probably my favorite
character and it hurts me that people
don't think that much about him I
believe he has an important role to play
in the last season and has already
offered us some great moments what do
you think I actually agree with you
Antonio I think Jorah does still have a
role to play also I know many people
believe Jorah will sacrifice himself to
save Daenerys and although that is very
possible but I don't think jours gonna
die I think that will kind of defeat the
purpose of saving him from greyscale but
you are right though Jorah has been
around since the very beginning he was
in the very first episode of this series
and I believe he will be in the very
last episode as well I actually made it
videos several months ago and it was
about Jorah surviving the Game of
Thrones Jorah Mormont story began with
him being a disgraced member of house
Mormont who was on the run from Ned
Stark's justice but now he is seen as a
man of honor by Ned Stark's own blood
and eventually Jorah will meet Lyanna
Mormont
I think Leona will accept him back into
the family once she learns about
everything that Jorah has done as of
lately Jorah did risk his own life to
help the king in the north
and now the greatest danger of this
world has ever known is knocking on
their backdoor the army of the Dead are
heading their way and Jorah could run
back to Essos if he wanted to but here
he stands ready to face whatever it is
the night king throws at them I also
think Sam will let Jorah use Hart's Bane
in the wars to
I don't think Sam's gonna be on the
battlefield that much but he will let
someone use his family's Valyrian steel
sword and since Sam already built a
relationship with Jorah I think he will
be the one to use it but these are just
my opinions the next question is from
Hanna Keller do you think Jon Snow and
Danni will have a boy or a girl could
the more beautiful woman coming to take
the throne be their daughter now in case
you are wondering what Hannah is
referring to this was a part of the
prophecy given to Cersei Lannister by
Maggy the Frog this prophecy has been
interpreted in many different ways fans
have always wondered who would be the
younger and more beautiful Queen to cast
Cersei down and take all that she holds
dear
could it be Margaery Tyrell Shawn's a
stark or even Daenerys Targaryen you
could probably make a case for all three
woman personally I always thought it
would be Daenerys Targaryen but you can
make a strong case for Margaery Tyrell
already having done this considering
Margaery more or less took Joffrey and
Tommen away from Cersei which we all
know Cersei loved her children almost
more than anything in the world but you
could also say ever since Margaery died
Cersei has become even more powerful
than she did before but Cersei has lost
everything else that she truly loved
personally I don't think it would be
John and Daenerys his child because I
think Cersei will be dead long before
their child would be able to do this
plus I think John and Daenerys will have
a son but it would be cool if Daenerys
gave birth to twins one being a boy and
one being a girl but that might be
asking for too much the next question is
from Adrian chin it sounds like you are
as passionate about Game of Thrones as I
am anyway question are they going to
create another spin-off show based on
Game of Thrones I am going to miss it so
bad yes they are currently working on a
successor show to Game of Thrones HBO
has actually hired five different
writers to come up with five different
shows based on the world that george RR
martin has created they're gonna try and
turn these five scripts into five pilots
then hopefully at least one of them are
good enough to get turned into another
hit series but if we are really lucky
then they might actually create more
than one new show since they are
currently writing five new
but don't hold your breath for more than
one right now because most pilots do not
get picked up the good thing is george
RR martin is helping them create one so
that leads me to believe they are
working on something pretty good
that should get picked up and produced
after gameofthrones ends the next
question is from bradley miller i never
hear anybody address this question
what's gonna happen when Daenerys meet
Sam even though Sam and his father were
on bad terms Danny did kill his brother
and father I'm not sure Sam even knows
at the point where the story ends this
is actually a very good question Bradley
at least five people ask this same
question so I figured I better try and
answer this one the only problem is I
really don't know how they're going to
handle this I think you are right though
Sam does not know Daenerys killed his
father and brother the news of his
family being burned alive did reach the
Citadel but the archmaester did not tell
Sam and it wasn't mentioned since so I
don't think Sam knows I can really only
speculate but I would assume Sam would
be pretty upset that his brother was
burned alive I don't think he would care
that much about his father dying but his
brother is a different story this could
potentially cause some tension between
Sam and Daenerys and possibly even John
if he stands by Danny's decision but
ultimately they all need each other they
need Danny's dragon Sam knows this
because he has seen the threat for
himself and they all need Sam's
knowledge Sam might be heartbroken over
his brother's death but Daenerys did
give them a choice Sam's brother and
father did not have to die but they
chose to continue to support Cersei even
after defeat so maybe Sam will
rationalize it by looking at it that way
it's really hard to say how they will
handle this I just hope they don't
ignore it because it should be addressed
during season eight at some point Sam
will find out and we should see him
affected by this news the next question
is from Joel Mello do you think Cersei
will have this child the Frog which from
a flashback said she would only have
three children what she did with Jamie
the second part of your question I
already answered earlier in this video
but personally I do not think Cersei
will have this child
I believe she will have a miscarriage
and this will take her madness to an all
new level that will ultimately be her
demise we all know how much Cersei loves
her children and now that she lost them
all she is holding out hope that she
will have this new child that goes
against Maggie the frogs prophecy but in
the end Cersei will lose this child too
now that Jaime is gone she will truly
have nothing left after this Cersei will
have nothing to lose and will be willing
to do anything to defeat her enemies but
I think it will get her killed
one misstep in Cersei is gonzo the next
question is from Lenny see after all is
said and done in the end what main
characters do you think will still be
alive well there are really only a
handful of characters that I would be
willing to bet on surviving everything
the characters that I think will live
are Samwell Tarly Gentry Baratheon
that's right he's a Baratheon in my eyes
Tyrion Lannister The Onion Knight sir
Davos Seaworth
Podrick big package Payne Jorah Mormont
Lyanna Mormont
Gillian baby Sam missandei brain stark
and Jon Snow just off the top of my head
those are the characters that I am
confident enough to say they will
survive somehow someway if you want to
know why I think these characters will
live then go check out the videos are
made about who I think survives this
deadly game of Thrones because it would
take up too much time to explain each
character's fate in this video the next
question is from Virginia Moore I have
been wondering about this for a while I
was disappointed with Varys in season
seven he practically did nothing what's
that about I thought he had a vast
network of spies
so what possible use could he have in
season eight you are absolutely right
Virginia Varys was another one of those
characters that were just put on the
sidelines he was even at the dragon pit
scene with the majority of the main cast
and he didn't say a word but there was
something interesting that was supposed
to happen during that dragon pit scene
that they ended up cutting out of the
show but it's technically not a deleted
scene but it was in the script and for
some reason they never did it at some
point during the dragon pit scene Varys
was supposed to have a talk with one of
the little birds Varys was going to ask
one of them about Kai
burn and she says he gives them sweets
and looks after them varus was then
going to say that is good do you know
what is better than having a good friend
to good friends that scene was in the
season seven plot leak that was 99.9%
accurate so it appears as if they were
going to show varus connect with his
network again but they didn't do this
for whatever reason I guess it is
possible they introduced this during
season 8 but that's only speculation at
this point I honestly think the
showrunners have no idea what to do at
varus right now which is why he is going
to die next season
just like Melisandre said he would I
made a video about this as well it's
called the death of varus check that out
I think I made a pretty good case for
how and why varus will die next season I
will answer one more than I will end the
video for today the last question is
from Hill Babineaux what do you think
the very last scene from the sixth
episode will be about this was kind of a
tough question because there are
actually a handful of things I think
they can do as the final scene of this
series there are a few different final
scenes I have in mind that I think would
be kind of cool one of the things I
think they could do is have ice reforged
again right as the show is about to end
we could get a very similar scene of
when ice was melted down into two swords
but this time we could see the two
swords being melted down and turned back
into ice again the stark theme music
could be playing as Gendry is forging
ice again for the Starks and as he
places ice on the mantle and Winterfell
the camera can slowly zoom out and fade
to black with the music still playing
softly or the final scene could be the
Iron Throne being destroyed the Iron
Throne has been the symbol of power and
corruption for the entire story the
struggle over who sits on this throne
has nearly destroyed the realm but after
all the big wars are over and the Seven
Kingdoms are in ruins there could be a
sign of hope when this series ends even
though some of our favorite characters
will be dead there may be just enough
decent people around to give us that
dream of spring and it can start with
the iron throne being destroyed or
melted down right as the last episode is
about to fade to black we could see the
Iron Throne being broken down into pea
says more the final scene could do
something simple like the birth of the
Narus and John's child whatever it is I
am thinking it will be some sign of hope
after all that we have been through over
the course of this series I think it
needs to end with some sort of hope some
dream of spring even if 90% of the
characters are dead and all the castles
have fell just give us something that
lets us know things will be restored in
due time that's all I ask
but if you have an idea for a great
ending scene put it down in the comments
because I would love to read it once
again I want to thank everyone for
stopping by and watching this video
I always appreciate anyone willing to
take time out of their day to watch one
of my videos I hope to see you all come
back for the next one and thank you to
everyone on patreon as well who
continues to support this channel during
this long night I hope you all have a
great day I will see you in the next one
bye
[Music]
[Music]